Number ten
how are you
I'm fine thank you how are you I'm
fine thank you how is the weather today
bye again bye ok the weather is
fine
[Music]
it's not sunny it's not
raining it's not raining it's not raining and yo I'm fine it's not
rainy it's nice nice
it's nice hello nice
[Music  ]
this weekend was good I
took a short vacation I took a vacation one day until I followed a vacation You took
a
vacation
You did you did you did you did you did it just like you I took a
evening
morning
Yes so the
day is
my angel day
Start start start start start start
started started So started
today
Selena with your
wife
her it
very nice very very very Do you play golf
Yes
because because my wife
[Music] can
see she sleeps
she loves to play very bad very bad
If
my wife e e
e something e
my wife loves to play golf
so I play
[Music] with her
[Music] is
good Yes, what is your favorite game? It's
more active than Sevdiye
[Music] is
moving to moving,
I like Ford for example
Okey
so I have a lot of work to get old every
week
[Music]
plays Golf four times
but
I'm the same for the first time
my name is understood ok
I
have a meeting in maniola last week
Well I
came to the construction site in total
I went to the meeting I went to the meeting
Yes I got mad at
me
I love the Mondial Meal too late I love it very
much g interesting meeting
If
Well what was the meeting about the meeting
What did you do about the values ​​of Ee languages
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
ok the meeting was about languages
that thing
Ancient city meetings O
year year lemm some sometimes
sometimes every some cut sometimes a few times
a single stone Yes Well
so
there are people who can speak many languages ​​people
together
home one more
meeting they are holding a meeting
Oha
how is learning a language
language languages
learn
languages ​​or
have a lot of interest in language
There is no end, there are presentations
my dear I have
ee ee
English mountain
polissant lingoes
word-for-word
language not much
talk can speak it
can speak hours people can speak it E boneguard
not much
[Music]
Hadise
İSMEK
Yes its name is not much Yes not much
consciousness of speakers egoistic language consciousness
language awareness is
very interesting English Witch
a-list let's come 2 oh my god it has
12 meanings attention
one thin
consciousness not too much
let's talk human everyone person one thin
second hand
linguistics
grammar grammar
linguistics science
Ee study study
always study Time
linguistics study human  human or
linguist language is not first but
not in
European
language
let's sow more
[Music]
this case is more common common common but in
English my hand is more common
I understand
Yes we also linguist a little more
Academic ne a little more academic endem
maybe e e e
learning a language
la  learning lan to the
first one
it's not the most important it's not important
two
different health thing yes yes meat you are right
it is not
I love getting married very much but
not my knowledge about it
and
I do
n't know anything about it I don't know about it I do
n't care Yes I don't care I don't
believe the hand I don't
know anything Yes
morryel
about that kind of meeting there for AKP auto for that meeting
[Music]
is a good city la
because
most
people English and French
They know they know they know they know they can speak or they can
talk to the
other should be
stopped
, you can sleep and
hear you can
hear you can hear more Arabic
too much more so too much
other Turkish speaking
okay Turkish -speaking
father
meeting
when I came to the meeting of
people EE 23
and
Turkish people EE.  ü Dan has
just arrived ha migrant
migrant drinking drinking
Yes ok migrant
[Music]
So
I'm
little
Turkish Turkish
Eda
chat
Speak talk
What should I talk
I talked I talked to you, I talked to you.
Well, did you make a
presentation?
and YouTube
more  Every class about Hunter
[Music]
[Applause]
website
circle
wrestling I
will finish it will change it
will
show will show Yes they will change
it will bring it to generations
I
YouTube If on the channel
[Music]
I made a video about my dear
nice Yes yes ok so
when was this meeting what Yes
Ee home
a  top Anyway brother August August
from 22 to
20-25
I get it
Between August 22-25 it's
ok I'll check it out I'll look at YouTube
Well, are you watching a Turkish series or a Turkish movie these days
Yes
every evening with my wife
Baba is dear name Baba is dear very bad
My love is
so stupid
come to this medicine but it's very interesting very nice
you
know Sefam it's funny funny very funny
always
okay
okay time
for example I don't want all of it now I
don't watch my wife watch for
two hours
watch
ryze if you want if you want my father
20 20 minutes 20 minutes if you want
then
watch the time he watches yes
he
because the
story
it's not very interesting but it did
n't
hurt more fine good years very
bad I liked it very much but I am
my mother in
Turkish
bucket da
mother Hello I
don't
understand most of
it I don't understand Most of
it  I don't need to watch
it Yes Turkish TV series are too
long too long long too long
I'm very sorry ha ha
but
every evening
we're fine with the series
Well watch time
Yes
I am Turkish
Turkey
Action
together
my son Ha ha You feel it
every evening when I watch the series
every evening
I'm in Izmir when I watch and watch the
Turkish circus with my family
No no, there is value in life ha Ha
yes yes
I feel like with them I write now
and
life is not life life is in
Istanbul
e well
this life is in life
If I believe in TV series If I'm tired,
everyone is rich in Istanbul. Everyone has
a mustache and a mustache.
i
have car cars car car car
car car car car car
doesn't
it matter Yes yes yes Serial and reality
Life is different different between real life
and private Yes yes there is a lot of difference Both
but
it's not so important
Because
yes yes it's fun It's something E
fun  endem special especially E I am
foreign foreigner a
place foreigner in my dream
score
as a foreigner as a foreigner Hey
enter the plane ya very interesting very interesting
not at all now on a
trip to Turkey or Turkey
[Music]
I love to do [Music] I want to
do more I want to travel
bread  I want to travel for the first time I
want to travel better price is
good I want but do
n't bother to enter
Turkey before you go to Turkey so before you go to Turkey or before you go somewhere
Turkey prepare to
a better level in Turkish
[Applause]
Levye pity on that love
ha  ha
I understand
it is better before I go to Turkey o
I need Turkish at this level I
need a better level v  ar
Yes, but you've only been learning Turkish for
three months, right? I don't understand it for three months
Ok
ichiru with tea and tea I'm
Ee by the way,
it
's the last half of the lesson today E
you tell me
I
told you I told you as I said
every
Harry tea Efe Ee I can't
learn 13 months
arabic arabic
Turkish
every  month
three months not every
So
[Music]
now
last Turkish lesson to the
river Ender
Nestle next minute end Yes
end
Language
Arabic Arabic Yes I am
starting and starting Arabic again but starting Arabic I am
waiting
ha
Yes
Well this month
I am visiting with my wife Ee
If it's because
it's good nevlin
Well everything evelyn day energy and ok let
me get the wedding
anniversary wedding anniversary
marriage
primary
marriage marriage very beautiful wedding
anniversary okeyev
this wedding anniversary
[Music]
Well me eli
Elif 50 50
wedding wedding year
anniversary
unit anniversary new Yesterday brain  anniversary
anniversary return fiftieth marriage
50 50
years of marriage  anniversary,
fiftieth wedding
anniversary, when the Gulf comes out, I'm also
Pro Clash Royale
Croatia Croatia
and and Spain
Ee home is
entered at night
outgoing George tonight ha ha
we'll go we'll go we'll go we'll go we'll go we're going to go we're going to go we're going to
be proud of the week now
only two weeks
Euphrates crystal
[Laughter] If
Asian hervas is a
senior, if
amino Elif is very little, I
want to get married a little bit, I
want to learn comfortably I want to see
it Yes because when we
are in
Croatia, I want to understand, but if we say we are in
Croatia  To To To From October
first October
Let's start with Arabic again
On October 1, head to head again, again on October 1,
I start Arabic again, on October 1 I start again with my head again
this way
so a Arabic for
33 months
learn Arabic for 33 months at all for a month learn Arabic at
night later
I wo
n't
learn again learn learn learn I will learn
more beautiful three months
After learning Arabic throughout,
after learning after learning, after learning, I
will learn ha ha I will suggest I will learn I will learn
if so
ee ee the
most
annoying year half a year I will eat
I
will eat I will eat again
o
I usually travel to
learn languages, but when I learn where to see
when I learn not
only
once but once
shocked to our site Gaziantep new
o When I learn, when I
concentrate on only one language, I become a wish
and a
rabbit and I become but
[Music]
now a
new new one  way to new individual baby
weapon clan May
[Music]
Captivity I decided to
use it
I don't know Well good good or bad I don't know I don't know
Of course home
Persian meat again
When I started, when time started from AK
Party,
I
was going to make some flour, I was going
to
forget something, will you tell me again, can you tell me
again
and again, it started in Arabic-Persian again and again,
but sometimes some words
will be home, I will die ha
ha okay
, we can say that he forgot  I
will always be forgetting
[Music]
I'm
always going to be something house Belli
obvious O my hand with words the words are obvious
certain thing forget the grinding
preceded you learn again Anyway better e e e remember I eat knows ha ha I can remember better  turns look what i
'll eat Yes
This is what kind of road this
New year what kind of road
goal
new you know what usually
before
[Music]
one one time
one if what is the most
sir
now also
not
learning e learning home but Ee
also not
three  month
month not one and not the
other at the end not the
second then not the second then
first place  I understand Yes huh
I
feel not learning If that's why
it's
interesting with
me It's interesting for me interesting for me interesting for
me you're right Very interesting for me too
yes
Well when does your trip start
not Elif Elif September September Elif
Ya
mom mom
thin melts 12 September 12  September 12 September
wants from color
but the
plane
Poet defy Ha Ha yes not on September 12
but we are flying we are flying
then we are flying from
Amsterdam
to the city to the city the shape of the city in Croatia
planet traveling traveling traveling
If to
Bosnia
Sarayevo Mostar
de Browning
Browning
a lot of
interesting things ya
[Music]
Well at the same time
[Music] in the
sea
walk to the seas
swim Izmir swim
kk100 May we go home we
swim or swim 7 we know
if then
September September September  September
20 20
24 24 September accompanied by da
Spain to Barcelona
on
24 September to Barcelona
We drink tea in three months, we fly, we fly, we're
flying,
we're flying,
endem Look to Catalonia, Eda is
n't on,
visit there,
come and say come come I 10 we are a power
travel or stay 11 the
idea is it's
very good moral more
faulty to the catalan
universe
Come on,
maybe as much as catalan  I'm going to do it or something,
learner in Catalan, I
won't learn. I won't learn.
Let's see how I can't give. I'll learn how to give.
Take
who
knows who knows.
Yes, you
know
Spanish. Spanish Spanish I know
Spanish branded. I
can speak Spanish. When did you learn
Spanish?
I was a student 50 50
years ago me places first
holidays time
vacation time sex
I came to Spain
hitchhiking
very good on vacation
I often went to Spain I went to Spain land of Atos of course
every day is spanish
[Music] Call
this Ismail Ismail
with Spanish with Spanish  ehe
hitchhiking
Atos cannon
No need Yes
need to speak I need to talk
I
then
Spain Spain ca
Spanish Spanish
Let's learn Spanish learning Spanish I learned I learned I
learned
but Spanish
This plan is
m-xylene Mecca
it's an
opportunity opportunity
very bad very bad not very bad
time
Spain Spain oil home
Well everything
Four eyes look forward to saying look
forward to it Yes I am
looking forward to going to Spain I am looking forward to going Spain I am
looking forward to going
[Music
] Very nice Yes
Golf Golf in Spain
This is Ee with
my wife to the fore
we will play pirate Jack we
will play we will play
I went to Spain why
he went he went
loop why this write go to
Spain
So decide to go there  searches gave home
what we decided to
go there Also
fiftieth
wedding
year
How
is
it yesterday anniversary in it a very nice
beautiful celebration
We are a beautiful celebration Kitty celebration
celebration this mass but free Mustafa
traffic celebration eyes Yes yes
very beautiful 50 years
Yes what about
Turkey?  When are you thinking of
coming?
everything If some science chair
flipped a Yes it was a little late, but it was worth it,
but the
power was not the most interesting thing,
but Ee my wife
started watching Netflix's Çelik serials Yigit started watching I started watching
I also started watching Then I started watching
it in Turkish
[Music]
this  I decided to like my home learning my home
learning to look Kara's
So now
Turkish  I want
to travel to iye
I
don't know when
but
maybe
next year Who next year Next year You
there
next year Not next year or
after that Look at that home or after that ee
Sure Of course a Ee Ya just me
[Music]
I want to go to Turkey,
no, my wife, she
wants to go to [Music],
Love still enters the house, Istanbul Izmir
Antalya
TV series Legends Well sometimes places Ömer
Abi
Adana Adana
Yes yes yes
enough food
music
scenery landscapes nervous this scenery
history every month is very bad  the worst
there are a lot of things
Yes there are a lot of things and every city is
different
I'm sure
I gave Emine yes yes but Antalya is very hot
very hot If the
beauties especially E but
we the most O us Viy us a we know
always
Hey
Bahar if
there is not more or E come on Thank you  autumn
fall autumn
e time travel yes we travel
the
deck of stories we travel we travel
or
fall we
travel in spring or autumn  we are waiting maybe
October
October October
October October Who is more
How is the weather in Antalya how is the weather very nice very nice
effective weather very good and not many tourists there
is no one beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
so Istanbul İzmir Antalya
Ürgüp endodontic east
Turkey Turkey this is about Turkey
If you very much  interesting
sense distinguish heard heard heard heard Yes
East of Turkey is very interesting I
heard I ate yes
Thank you Thank you
There were many interesting
lessons Eee there were So also the
screen
tomorrow come after the
task
See you bye See you bye Yes for me
the lessons were very good
videos on YouTube  watch this okey
thank you see you
bye bye bye mr